there is a poster that's been going
around all over the campus of the
University of Illinois at Chicago the
poster says in very large font ending
white privilege starts with ending
Jewish privilege and I'll read to you
some of the other things on this poster
quote Jewish Americans make up 2% of the
population 44% of these Jewish Americans
are in the top 1% and then it starts
breaking those statistics down into an
out of a thousand people sort of analogy
it's interesting how right-wing
anti-semitism strongly insists that Jews
aren't white but then you have left-wing
anti-semitism which I would consider
this poster falling under left-wing
anti-semitism which always insists that
Jews are white but first of all before
we even dig into that they don't even
correctly use the Pew source that they
cite to appear to be citing data at the
bottom of this poster it sources some
pew data but what the pew data actually
says is that 44 percent of American Jews
make $100,000 or more which does not put
44 percent of American Jews in the top
one percent earning a hundred thousand
dollars puts you in the twelve percent
the twelve percent doesn't have the
exact same ring to it that the one
percent has anyway not really the point
the point is that Jews are often and
once again unfairly the targets of
conspiracy theories and that's probably
how over $100,000 turned into the top
one percent but even if the data was
correct white people in general have had
historical privilege in the US for any
number of reasons right we could talk
about slavery stories about disease
metals guns ever there's just so many
different ways right but the Jewish
people in particular don't have any type
of undue privilege that's been handed to
them or that they've obtained unfairly
now Jews who appear to be white can
still be the beneficiaries of what is
generally considered to be white
privilege in Western society but recall
that Jews make up a microscopic minority
in the world and in every country on
earth
except for Israel Jews are one of the
most if not the most persecuted and
victimized peoples in human history
Jews are one of the most if not the most
dispersed peoples in the world today
other than again the few million Jews
that live in Israel and the only real
estate that Jews do have is constantly
threatened existential threats to the
safety to its safety by its neighbors
threats to its sovereignty because of
people throughout the world who don't
appreciate its right to exist or the
need for it and Jews have had a constant
need to relocate over the last several
thousand years due to exiles of all kind
so this has all emphasized the need for
a mobile form of what we would call
capital education if Jews are successful
it can be attributed to lack of
privilege and discrimination for
thousands of years liberal arts academia
almost universally has an irrational
anti-jewish or or at minimum and it's
two different things to be clear anti
Israeli agenda I've seen it personally
both the right and the left are rampant
with anti-semitism both explicit and
implicit of different kinds Jews are
still one of the only oppressed
minorities that too many people still
fail to see as being victims of
marginalization and bigotry because of
posters like this that circulate on
college campuses and here's the real
question to ask about this poster
because you'll often see stuff like this
and people say we're just making people
aware of the facts okay well what do you
suggest be done to end so-called Jewish
privilege if you're somebody who's
putting this poster out there do you
want to limit the number of Jews that
can go to colleges do you want to tax
Jewish owned businesses or some other
kind of Jew tax where do you plan to go
with this if you've identified this
issue that you want to solve please
explain where you want to go in looking
for a solution and then maybe we can
figure out what this is really all about